hello folks and welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics rationally well does
physics You full stop okay uh we're
gonna have a a special day today because
uh I don't always find my son I never
know where he's at okay so today I found
him and so because of that we're going
to do something we want to do for quite
a long time and that's uh have him an
ask questions out of the blue because I
don't know what he's going to ask and I
got to answer them and they're related
mostly uh with the uh rope model of
light and gravity okay I mean if we get
there and you said you had a bunch of
things you have to answer first there
were there were several questions I'm
going to go through the questions that
uh people ask first okay and uh and then
we're going to move on to that to those
questions and of course uh people are
welcome to ask questions okay uh and
we're going to try to answer those as
well they can be on any topic really
okay and I hope we are still online I
hope we are yeah I heard it yeah oh
you're hearing okay T my beard a bit I
look like a villain okay so let's go
with the first uh question or comment
that people made related I'm going to do
the first Extinction there's uh like
four questions there so let me address
those first says whether from infections
or immune activ activation in the womb
chemicals and electromagnetic stressers
or a
neuroinflammatory profile other than in
the case of BL La no hard genetic cause
has been found a lot of people believe
that um
autism is related to chemical activity
and not to uh what we propose here and
that is that it's got at least something
to do or quite a bit to do with
um the fact that we've lost genetic
diversity that's that's my argument okay
and people question that especially
people who go against vaccines uh who
believe that the corporations are
poisoning us with a lot of chemicals
that they put it with in the food and
things of that nature okay and another
fell along the same lines he says lack
of genetic diversity never prevented
rabbits cats or camels from overtaking
the country uh the mouse experiment also
blame population density so what
explains Mass homosexuality and autism
in rural
Australia okay I think the problem is
chemical again all these people believe
that chemistry right it comes from
polluted food or polluted
medicines okay so yeah lots of people um
today especially those uh who are a
little weary about you know the the
government uh intervening in their life
lives they believe there is this
conspiracy I guess uh it is a conspiracy
theory in a in a sense there is some
truth to it I'm not going to say that it
doesn't affect us at all but uh I don't
think that's the primary mover for why
we're having some of these we could say
mental problems that we put them all
together okay uh personally I think a
lot of that has to do primarily with
genetic diversity we lost it and uh
secondary maybe density has something to
do with it we're all in the cities we're
all cramped in there more or less and
you know we don't know who our neighbor
is anymore even though he lives next
door you know in an apartment and so I
think that's got some effect on people
the educational system okay A little bit
of that but if I had to weigh it on the
scale I would say that 80% of it at
least has to do with genetic diversity
and part of that the reason I think that
way is because of Calhoun's experiments
showed that after um after two years
that the mice were multiplying okay for
those of you who know the what happened
there um you know they came first from
the same stock okay we have the founders
effect there and that's followed by the
fact that you know the they had density
uh you know after a while you had a
th000 mice and after a little while you
had 2,000 mice always in the same space
and so I think those are the primary
factors and I think that's what's
happening to humans as well which was by
the way the conclusion of koun okay that
they went berserk uh all these mice
because of density he didn't even not I
don't think he considered founders
effect maybe he did I don't know but uh
I I would say that's probably the
primary cause and here we have uh
another F along the same lines I'm
really getting tired of your religion of
clones there's uh more difference
between me and my fellow man than there
is between all uh all the dogs wolves
and coyotes in the world um I think
that's not true okay I think he's got
his data wrong I think wool dogs wolves
and coyotes are different species we are
the same species different races and so
um I don't think what he he's saying
there is not true I don't think that's
that's a fact okay um and he says we are
a diverse huge species cluster and we
are certainly aren't having any
inbreeding troubles I'm going to dispute
that here we have a case of The Chimps
okay um some news from the past 2012
chimpanzee populations living in
relatively close proximity are
substantially more different genetically
than humans living on different
continents they had like a 100 chimps
and it had more genetic diversity than
the entire human race and so uh I think
that's the first bit of uh you know data
right take it for what you want and
here's another okay
oh
side and here's the other one let's see
if we can get this up
here these are the couple cases one is
Charles second of Spain known as El Eis
the B witch
and he was from the Habsburg family
which did a lot of inbreeding for a
couple Generations by the time you get
to the 1700 he was uh he had problem
mental problems and then you have the
romanovs uh they came all from Queen
Victoria and they also in inbred and by
the time Alexa came up uh in the early
1900s um he had homophilia in fact it
was said that that's the disease of the
kings of the SARS right and theam are
having all kinds of problems genetic
problems of different nature uh in fact
some rare genetic diseases uh because of
what 350 years of inbreeding they came
all from the same stock so it's a great
experiment really in which they all
inbred for you know 300 years and from
like a stock of maybe anywhere between
1500 to 2,000 people we have 3 50,000
Amish today and yeah after 300 years you
would expect of in breeding you would
expect to see some problems and there
you can see uh what's happened with
humans okay if we go with the earliest
man humanik creature which would be Ood
right 300,000 years ago uh to today you
know uh I think we had a lot of
inbreeding uh we all come from that
stock some Adam and Eve not not
literally true but uh you know we can
trace our lineage to about 300,000 years
ago and yeah I think that uh we've been
in breeding for quite a while and now
we're starting to see some of the
problems especially because what we have
density okay that means that you know we
are um all in the same city okay you um
maybe have the girl next door and the
girl across the street that's you marry
or you marry someone in your town or
within your race and I think that uh all
contributes to our loss of genetic
diversity anyways that's my take on on
that briefly right um and then the last
one here I
says says please make a video on your
opinion of Danny vandrin Neanderthal
predation
Theory um I have talked about vendramini
in the past not I didn't make an entire
video video on him but uh here's a
summary okay that came out of uh the
book he's selling out there and he says
the evolution of modern humans is the
result of systematic long-term sexual
predation and cannibalism by Eurasian
neanderthals we turn to complex social
societies to fight them
off okay I got a couple problem with
when vendramini saying the first one um
I'm GNA have a problem with his uh his
version of nandal there you can see uh
looks little
monstery he's a little monster look at
the face and uh I think this is a little
Hollywood esque I would go more with the
uh one
Boule Drew in 1909 which was the
original notion that we had of nandal
and I think I would prefer any of those
anyways to the one in 2015 where the guy
uh is
um uh it's that white guy there and I
think if a girl had to choose I think of
all three of them she would sleep with a
guy on the right not with a any of the
other two and yeah if you make the uh
one on the right if you make nandal more
um you know desirable to women than we
can all imagine yeah we did sleep with
an nals and we had and that's how they
disappeared you know so what they're
trying to sell you is the extinction
Theory based on uh intermarriage with an
anderol and of course if you put the
other two fellas there and very few
people will believe it but uh the
question is um you know what did nandal
look like I think it's important and I
would say that uh Nal was The Woolly man
he looked like that guy on the left
first and I think uh if if I if it were
me I would put more hair on him he this
fellow lived in uh very cold climates he
lived in uh Europe at the time Europe
had glaciers that extended way down
south so this guy was a snowman he was a
jti jti Yeti Yeti uh abominal snowman
you know so and I I would think he was
hay uh so I don't think that guy in
white I don't think that's the guy that
looked like Nal at all yeah so I think
all I think all they're trying well I
put the diaper in it but because I mean
it's so ridiculous for them to put such
a white guy you know uh just hair in his
chest looking good you know the girls
would say well I would sleep with that
guy you know yeah no kidding that's why
they can sell the the interbreeding
theory but that's only they put a monkey
like yeah that's the point doesn't sell
as well and that's the point okay
getting uh into the physics stuff uh
here we have a file says the following
he says Ah
here how come I can't see
that oh it's got the little eye huh tou
oh is that what it is okay okay so so
here he is um one fell says none of them
are dimensions they are number line oh
no that's what I said I'm sorry and he
said so may uh many misunderstanding
here it's clear from that statement you
don't understand what a dimension even
is okay I don't know what a dimension is
number lines are dimensions states of
being are dimensions any descriptive
term is a dimension at least could be
and these are what dimensions are or
what a dimension is okay so this F says
the dimensions everything dimensions are
anything you can think of you know they
just put them in there and say anything
you can think of at least you know any
descriptive term is a dimension state of
color could be a dimension yeah
everything even God is a dimension you
know so the problem here is again uh
people don't Define their terms and then
they tell me that I don't know what
dimension is okay so let's uh let's
educate this fellow okay let's let's
find out what he doesn't know okay
here's the first one now here's the
definition of Dimension this is uh from
the official literature out there one is
from the Wikipedia the other one is from
Wolfram they both basically the same say
the same thing first thing is they
clarify that Dimension is of a
mathematical space whatever that is or
object and the other one says dimension
of an object so we're more or less on
the same you know in the same ballpark
here uh and then it says the first one
says is informally defined as the
minimum number of coordinates
needed to specify any point within it
and the other one says something similar
says is a topological measure of the
size of its covering properties roughly
speaking it is the number of coordinates
needed to specify a point on an object
so they're both saying the same thing
it's the number of numbers because
that's what a coordinate is here we see
uh what the definition of coordinate is
more or less let me get this up here and
a coordinate system is a system that
uses one or more what numbers or
coordinates so what is a coordinate it's
a number to uniquely determine the
position of the point uh uh or other
geometric element on a manifold such as
ukian space so what do they say they say
it's the same thing it's the number of
numbers needed to specify a point that's
essentially what a coordinate and a
dimension is they're both they're
synonyms there's no difference between
the word coordinate and the word
Dimension according to these people and
there you see the Wolfram says a set of
variables which fix a geometric object
if the coordinates are distances
measured along perpendicular axis right
and they're talking about distance
traveled meaning what number lines they
are known as cartisian number lines but
they call them
coordinates Dimensions equal number
lines yeah essentially uh not really I'm
going to specify that right now clarify
that right now and uh so what is a
coordinate what is a dimension number of
numbers that's all needed to specify a
point in
ukian space that's more or less what it
is on a GD yeah on a grid or whatever
and so um here we have what what it
really is I mean for the purposes of
physics we're doing physics here right
we don't care about math okay so here
we're doing physics and here you see the
differences between physics and math the
ones on the top physics the ones on the
bottom the one on the bottom math okay
Dimension length width and height okay
that's it three dimensions you want two
of them length and height length and
width no problem width and height we'll
we'll go with that but what do they talk
about they talk about or what are they
refer to orientation of an object how it
looks you know from a given what how it
faces in other words coordinate has to
do with locations and you can see the
arrows pointed the opposite direction
they Point towards the object you have
an a for example a room and you're going
to locate that object within the room
with these uh so-called coordinates
right that we use in physics and what
are they longitude altitude and latitude
and then uh vectors what are vectors
they're direction of motion we have
motion there and again it's outwards
it's the three perpendic mutually
perpendicular directions that an object
can move in and there you have dep
breath and
elevation none of those are quantitative
they're only qualitative they have only
two uh properties and that's uh
Direction and perpendicularity
orthogonality what is uh what is what
does math use does math have any use for
these qualitative Notions absolutely not
uh what math uses is uh number lines and
uh all they have is magnitude and
Direction the problem with direction is
that uh direction is a qualitative
concept math has no use for qualitative
Concepts and so really all all they have
is this thing they call um uh number
line and they call them Dimensions
sometimes they call them coordinates and
they call them vectors you know it's all
the same thing to a
mathematicians uh so all I can tell you
is that yeah math does not use um
Dimensions at all or coordinates for
that matter they use number lines
everything in math has to do with
numbers only numbers so they use the
word dimensions and they call them
length width and height and then
immediately they put some number in
there talking about um how much you know
how long how how far that sort of thing
how much time so that's why how all
these number lines have become
dimensions and
coordinates okay next issue so we move
along here Paul says if I Dro My
Computer causing damage do you think uh
mathematical descriptions damaged the
computer or do you think forces did them
damage and he says the same thing for
the other one say or do you think field
did the damage and the same thing for uh
computer says do you think energy did
the damage and so he's talking about
forces fields and energies he say they
are
physical physical what do you mean
physical what does physical mean you
know and uh of course they don't Define
physical ever so they can use these
words they can say uh forces fields and
M and energies are X and as long as they
don't Define X you don't know what they
said that's the issue okay it says far
from being con conceptual only resetting
in the mind or minds of humans as
abstract idea ideas so that's what he
thinks are Concepts right Concepts is
just what resides in the mind okay yeah
if you define a concept that way uh then
uh you can get away with anything
because that's not a good definition
what do you mean reside in the mind you
know I mean uh does uh a tree fit in
your brain is that what it is that's how
it resides in there you know uh so you
got to Define really what a concept is
and that's uh not a
rational definition certainly it's the
one he just copied out of a book a
dictionary or whatever and he calls it
oh this is this is the definition of
concept you know even to this day
philosophers like at the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy are debating
what the hell is a concept right and
yeah we have a problem because here you
have uh these are the these are
definition that you find there here's
the one for Force okay strength of or
energy as an attribute or action of
movement that's out of Oxford dictionary
Force an influence that's what it is
influence I guess influenza when you get
the flu that's a force that can cause an
object to change its velocity okay so
that's what the force is uh what is
field field a physical quantity so we're
talking about a quantity okay that's
what a field is he says it's physical
can a can we say that a quantity is
physical
and it says uh represented by a number
okay so yeah a field is always a bunch
of numbers that's all it is and what it
what is it that has a value for each
point in space and time so all they're
saying is you you know you look at the
strength of the field that's essentially
what they look at and they put numbers
in units that um extend uh ever weaker
uh from the far they get from uh Ground
Zero okay and uh so that's a feel if you
take the all those numbers put together
that's a field so it's a bunch of
numbers uh field the influence that's
according to dictionary.com the
influence it's an influence that that's
what I feel is of some agent of some
agent whatever agent it's like the agent
doesn't count or that field is not an
agent it's just the influence of the
agent right as electricity or
gravitation considered as existing at
all points in space right because just a
bunch of numbers they just talk about
the strength of the field not the field
itself field is the whole thing is a
it's a bunch of strengths you could say
you know bunch of numbers with units and
defined by the force it would exert on
an object placed at any point in space
and uh then what do we have we have
energy what is energy well here we have
it our good friend uh Richard feineman
Nobel Prize right uh he told us what it
is it is important to realize in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is had no clue whatsoever well
it's vaguely defined well obviously well
you can see how it's defined energy the
capacity and then you look at elsewhere
says energy the quantitative property so
so no these things are not physical as
this fellow suggests and absolutely not
they're not uh you know we don't have
any physicality to these concept these
are Concepts and concepts are not what
is in the mind concept is simply a
relation between two uh objects okay and
who performs it a human without humans
we have no Concepts really out there we
created all the concept mother n did all
the objects we did Concepts yeah okay
that's the way it works okay another
fellow along the same line talks about
field what is a field well a field is a
movie he says yeah agreed it is a
perturbation perturbation that's a nice
word yeah I'd like to insult you you're
a
perturbation force is not energy it is
the opposite of energy it is the loss of
energy okay uh ether is not a movie
though it is nonc cartisian and he says
it's pure
potential okay so ether is just pure
potential so he's saying is you know why
it's per potential because whatever you
need it whatever you need he pulls it
out of the potential bag yeah either is
isn't isn't until whatever you need then
yeah oh well you need Dark Energy ether
made the dark energy what else do you
need yeah but you know even in that that
case ether is uh misconstrued oh yeah
yeah because ether is is not just uh
energy or or movie or or or a non-movie
or potential whatever you want to call
it ether was a medium medium right that
was always in motion it was ether means
air Greek air medium that's in motion
yeah that's here it is in fact now we
have it Illustrated fortunately so you
don't have to break your head
not a fart is it there it is it is a
fart yeah there you have that's what the
ether is a bunch of particles that was
out there and the movement of that was
the after the after Robert Hook came up
with the wave notion of light um after
that uh The Ether was the light was
simply the undulation of The Ether and
what was it a bunch of particles that
are moving up and down that's what it
was all the way to the end of the 19th
century when uh relativity and mon
mechanics over Through The Ether
supposedly all they did was really
change the name because we still have
the false vacuum in quantum mechanics
and we have uh in relativity what is
known as SpaceTime what is spacetime a
point at uh at each a a an event that
happens at each point in SpaceTime
that's what SpaceTime is and there you
have it each point in space time and
what they do they move around when they
move up and down you have what is known
as light wave nature of light okay so
that's essentially what it's always been
a bunch of particles that's all that
ether was ever since the days of the
Greeks nothing has ever changed and all
those people say Bill you don't know
what the ether is well but you never
tell me what it is don't tell me what it
ain't okay I want you to tell me what it
is and if it's and it is if it's a what
is if it's a thing point to it give me a
picture of it and if it's a concept
Define it very simple you either Define
or you draw and they never do either one
they say well you don't know what it is
yeah I know I'm I'm ignorant as you're
going to showed me today right no I'm
here I'm here to ask them hard questions
oh Jesus okay you'll see I'll get you no
plate of soup for you today okay here we
have another fell along the same line
let's replace space with the black sky
this guy's going to talk about The Ether
also in the black Sky there are many
bright dots that we call stars of
planets okay the black Sky instead of
being empty is full it is an object so
the black sky space he's saying it's an
object a thing okay uh if it is draw it
that's what I say you know and tell me
what gives it shape you know what's the
background right elaborating on Bill's
hypothesis threads and ropes the black
sky is all that mass of of threads and
ropes that are not structured like an
atom so he's saying you have the atoms
right that's what we call matter and we
have The Robe which everybody calls
energy you know the vibration of the
robes frequency times wavelength right
and and uh and he's saying that uh these
ropes they form this backdrop right and
he says it's The Ether okay the word
ether the medium that connects all
objects is an object and not nothing
okay so he's saying that ether is an
object because ether is all those
ropes uh maybe he includes the atom
maybe he doesn't but I think that's
irrelevant but at least the ropes are
included right and saying all the ropes
that's the same thing as space and
that's the same thing as ether it's all
one shig bang you know same thing and
yeah we have a little problem with what
he's saying because here you can
see a little picture that synthesizes
the problem here you have a bunch of
ropes going in every direction right and
the question is what's the black stuff
that gives shape to the Rope if the
ropes all the ropes together just the
ropes right that's the ether and that's
space and so what the black stuff that
gives shake to each individual rope
that's what he's got to identify the
black stuff and he can't say the black
stuff is space because he's saying that
the ropes are space that space uh ropes
and ether are all the same thing one and
the same he's saying that the ropes
cover every little bit of space and
that's what the ether is okay so that's
his argument and we're saying no because
you have to have two things there you
have to have the black stuff that gives
background to the green stuff which are
the ropes so you got to identify what
the black stuff is in this case and I
don't think he would understand anyways
you know what the issues are
here uh so well all I can do is just
throw that out there for him to answer
the question okay okay uh moving on here
we have another fellow also talking
about The Ether and he says ether is not
space okay we have one that says it is
space this one says it's not space okay
space is ether Shadow what what so it's
so when we have the vibration of The
Ether you know the Rope uh the I'm sorry
the wave okay the electromagnetic wave
he's saying that's a shadow that's
moving okay it's a shadow okay I guess
uh you have light casting on on this uh
ether on this uh ether thingy creates a
on on what uh on ether and gives you the
shadow which is space the spa space is
what's the shadow okay okay so what's
The Ether then right and ether cannot be
pointed to because it has no cartisian I
don't know what that means because if
you should be able to point to it if the
ether casts a shadow which is space
right so if space is the shadow of ether
ether had better be a thing like a tree
you know uh then then you can cast a
shadow otherwise you can't have a
concept that uh cast a shadow and he
says ether is not a concept nor is it an
object okay so he he killed me I don't
know he has a third category well he's
got to identify what category it falls
under okay all Concepts and objects are
ether perturbed I mean you either have
shape or you don't the third one yeah
but uh that's kind of maybe have shape
when you need it but not having shape
when you don't it's what these people
never Define their terms that's why they
get away they murder the whole point is
they get they specifically don't Define
it so that they can get away with murder
but they don't realize how important it
is to define words they think that's
word uh salad and semantics and grammar
and he says I came here to do physics
not to do semantics you know okay
another fell talking about plasma okay
here we have the plasma is the fourth
state of matter famous state of matter
electrons in a solid liquid or gases
sample of matter stay with the same
atomic nucleus okay and what happens
when you excite them heating a gas will
form a plasma why because electrons are
ripped away from the atoms forming an
ionized gas so what what is ionized gas
means that you're going to strip an
electron away from them through some
process that means the plasma which is
an ion a bunch of ionized atoms right
means that they're excited somehow by
something we don't care about that at
this point we just care to what is the
plasma and the plasma is an ongoing
process it never stands still so you
can't take a picture of plasma and say
oh I took a picture of plasma now you
did not take a picture of plasma okay
once you take a picture that's not
plasma because the word plasma means
something in motion and what I'm staring
at is not is not in motion okay so we
got a problem with a picture that you
took of the plasma ball saying hey
that's plasma inside there no no that's
not plasma because plasma is always in
motion plasma is a movie it's never a
photograph okay that's the way the word
plasma is defined and it takes 100 years
for these people to understand that
plasma is a form of matter in which
electrons migrate yeah they're
constantly migrate around the nuclear of
the uh nucle of the atoms so plasma is
always in motion if you take a picture
of plasma that picture is not of plasma
you can't call that plasma because
plasma is always in motion you're
reading more into the picture than what
is there okay the word plasma is a
running boy not a boy okay word plasma
means flying eagle not Eagle okay so if
I take a picture of a flying eagle what
I have in the picture is an eagle not a
flying eagle I'm putting more into the
picture than what is there all I have
there is Eagle not flying eagle and
swimming fish uh should I go through all
the animals maybe you know a fish if I
take a picture of a swimming fish when I
see a fish in the ocean or in the river
whatever right in the water I don't see
swimming swimming if I want to take a
picture of swimming I need a movie I
can't take a picture of swimming and you
can't take a picture of iron ionizing if
the gas is ionizing constantly ionizing
I'm not taking a picture of ionizing I'm
taking a picture of the atom or an you
know an atom that that has a little ball
next to it which is the electron little
bead there but I'm not taking a picture
of plasma I'm taking a picture of I I
can't take a picture of
ionizing okay that's the point okay and
these people have a hard time
understanding that so here let's go with
the state first
okay here we have plasma is not a state
of matter move this over here cover your
face I want to be I want to
talk so as we can see here so plasma is
not a state of matter why state is a
static concept and uh Plasma's the one
on the bottom ionizing so you can't take
a picture of ionizing okay can't be a
state of matter what about taking a
picture of ionized in the past tense
yeah again uh if any picture I take I'll
have a static image I'll have you know
no motion and the word ionizing and the
word plasma both have um are running
well hold on let me stop you there
there's a difference between burning and
burnt a burnt kangaroo yeah isn't a
kangaroo it's a burnt kangaroo yeah
there's no such thing as an adjective in
physics yeah I got you but but what
would you call the chunk of just burnt
meat it's not burnt meat what would you
call it no no but I mean first you have
to identify the object you can say
that's a kangaroo now if it's burnt now
you're going to talk about something
else that that the burnt kangaroo what
would you call it if it's not a burnt
kangaroo no I'm saying that there's no
object called burnt kangaroo all what
would you call it then if you it after
you point to the kangaroo you can say
the kangaroo is burnt no and the fish
will be swimming it's not a kangaroo
anymore so you can't call it you call it
a bunch of carbon but it's not carbon
yet I don't know uh whatever you have
there I don't wouldn't it be easier to
call it a burnt kangaroo yeah but that
you can call it you can call it a burnt
kangaroo what I'm saying is there's no
object called a burnt
kangaroo okay there's no object called
burnt that's the point you don't look at
the the noun you look at the adjective
or the adverb and say can I can I put an
adjective a verb turned adjective well
by that I guess by the same token you
could you could add an infinite amount
of adjectives of where an object has
been you could say the object that was
down the street two minutes ago you
could add a bunch of qualifiers that
that are almost irrelevant to what the
object is
now yeah and and for that whether it got
burnt whether it got moved whether it
got dropped then what you're doing is
comparing because burnt means that it
wasn't burnt before it's like dead and
alive you say well that's a dead cat
like shro or dead cat but that means
that you're comparing that against alive
okay you're making a comparison but you
cannot take a picture of the comparison
of the concept known as burnt or dead or
alive or whatever you can take a picture
of cat and then describe it and say the
cat is burnt or whatever dead or
whatever but my point is there's no op
you when when you put an adjective and
you say I can take a picture of a dead
cat no you cannot not in physics you can
you can take a picture of cat but not of
dead but hold on hold on that is you're
putting more into the picture than what
is there okay then one more question to
that there are certain Atomic elements
that are
man-made right yeah yeah yeah uranium
well not uranium that comes natural but
the weird ones the weird ones like
Einsteinium whatever right those are man
manid we got lenium yeah but you
wouldn't call
lenium the because because
it's you'd almost say it's a process
because it's only there for a fraction
of a second so when you point at it are
are you calling it what it is now or how
it came to be well the point here is
again uh if it appears in our world in
the physical
world yeah okay for a millions of
gazillions of a second that gazillions
of you took a picture you took a picture
yeah let's say you were able to take a
picture the area of lenium in front of
you right isn't that like ionized gas
because it it there was a process to get
to it like burning a kangaroo but it is
in front of you as it is yeah but uh the
object that's in front of you is is a a
bunch of in this case under the Rope
model at least you know you have all
these balloons yeah it's a very compact
so yeah you you have this multiple
balloons one it's a weird Mass right
it's it's got all the you can take a
picture of that and say that that's
lenium and you can take a picture of I
don't know uranium and say look see how
different they are and say this is lenum
this is uranium even though they you
know they're radioactive and they
immediately but then why can't you have
a picture of gas and ionized gas look
how different they are no no because now
we're talking about something else
because
again in lenum you're taking a picture
of the atom a complex atom a bunch of
balloons I can put a bunch of balloons
together and say look this is what
lenium looks like and I take a picture
of just bunch of balloons right one
inside the other or TI you know clown
balloons right so I I build this model
and say that's lenum okay so I've got my
model and I can take a picture of it
nothing's happening the word lenum well
kind of cuz no it's not it's about to
explode we don't we don't care uh how it
got there or whether the next second it
disappears or breaks up or whatever all
we're saying at a certain moment we have
this lenum thing we took a picture
here's the picture of what lenum is or
what it looks like or whatever but you
can't do that with plasma or ionized
because you're not talking about what is
being plasma or what is being ionized
you're talking about the process there
the word plasma includes motion the word
ionized includes motion ionized uh when
you put in front of gas it's an
adjective but it was a verb that was
turned into an aditude ion ionization
means you're pulling an electron out
right so I kind of get it it's very the
question people think we're taking a
picture of plasma know you're taking a
picture of or trying to take a picture
of ionized or ionizing it's not so much
like lenum it's really more like fire
where you think of fire and if you take
a snapshot of fire and zoom in
you can't really see the fire that's why
fire is not a physical object you just
see the atoms fire is a process of
combustion and so so you can say so we
should use the word fire or plasma
because when you say plasma say well
plasma is a noun no no not in physics in
physics it's not a noun but it's weird
because the fire is not a noun either
well it isn't it Ain the reason why it
is is because well yeah obviously fire
is just like the breaking of light that
gives it shape but it isn't really
something that has shape it's no but
it's not the issue of shape it's the
word the word fire it's we should
replace it by what it means which is com
combustion you know burning yeah burning
oxygen or whatever so you you've got a
verb and you're trying to take a picture
of the verb not of the atom okay because
if I put an oxygen atom there and you
say well that's an oxygen atom no no
problem an atom right you can take a
picture of an atom but you cannot take a
picture of combustion okay combustion is
a process and so you need a movie for
that you can't take a picture of
combustion that's what people don't
understand when they say fire or when
they say plasma the issue so so language
is absolutely important but it's It's
tricky to define those because it's a
concept fire is a concept yeah because
you need concept because you need a
movie yeah you need a movie here you see
it in fact uh where was there you see it
see it's moving around so yeah so you
can't have it as a state I feel like
there's still something there but I'd
have to really dig deep into it to get a
good question I need I need a question
that'll really stomp you but here you
have Plasma on the left hand side we all
understand plasma because you're
watching a movie but you cannot take a
picture of plasma because all I see
there I don't see ion I don't see
ionizing what I see as atom is if
anything I see electrons but I don't see
ionizing for ionizing you need the left
one yeah there's still something there
but I can't get it yet something still
nags me but I can't put my finger on
okay next movie next week next week I'll
get you we're not this you win this time
okay a couple more okay and then we go
into the questions okay here's the first
one newton actually just proposed an
inverse Square relationship a proportion
not an exact equation this came after
Newton absolutely right Newton had no
equations in principia okay he had no
equations in there all he did was uh
have um
qualitative uh explanations in that
sense he was more of a physicist than
what you have today because he even
though he he knew quite a bit of math
okay he and he was very interested in
math in that sense he was interested in
how this universe works and he was at
least honest and says finger non
hypothesis he says I have no
clue that's what he said in Latin he
said he he didn't know how gravity works
and he said it was just so strange that
he would not be able to explain how you
know how gravity works from a distance
without a mediator and he could not
explain that but at least he was on the
right track okay but all he did in his
book he was explaining qualitatively
that looks like this gravity thingy has
to do with masses and the square of the
distance the inverse square of the dist
okay so that's all you know he he other
than that he said nothing more we have
someone to ask an Bill to pause the GI
and ask him what it is the plasma but
you already did that didn't you the what
the plasma is if you pause the if ask
them what it is yeah yeah yeah uh what
it is we call it plasma because we use
one word for it but we cannot take a
picture of ionizing keep I want you to
focus on that you're trying toly what
you did you had you had the frame take
the frame there and what you have is in
that picture what you have is atom we're
going to go with a Quantum version we
have the atom and an electron right
that's what we have and they're
separated they're not close together
they're separate that's what we're
staring at so far we see no motion we
don't know what's happening we know that
the atom lost that electron we don't
know any about that we don't have that
information in a single picture in a
single frame we are reading more into
the picture than what is there again I
like to use the the case of the flying
eagle or the swimming fish because when
I take a picture of a swimming fish or a
flying eagle I'm not taking a picture of
flying I'm taking a picture of eagle and
when someone say oh that's a flying
eagle no no that's not a flying that's
an eagle I can't take a picture of
flying yeah yeah flying I need at least
two then I can compare them say oh this
guy was here and then now it's over here
that's flying but in one picture I
cannot synthesize flying you're reading
more into the picture than what is there
same thing with plasma plasma you have
the electron separated from its atom
fine no problem but what do we have we
have an atom we have an electron that's
what that's what the picture shows yeah
that's full stop right there that says
it all that's all we have there now
ionizing that left I need two pictures I
think with that you you finally put it
to rest at least in my mind cuz yeah if
you take a picture of ionizing all you
have is an atom and an electron over
there yeah okay the last one here you're
the one that yeah you're the one that
says the atom is missing an electron but
you're but that's motion you're adding
motion
that reading more than what's there
you're saying an electron was removed
here you're already doing detective work
but no all is there is an is is an atom
a picture you cannot synthesize the verb
okay I think I got you okay and here's
the last one says fell says prove you
understand the normal accepted theories
saying I'm a dumb spring yeah you're
dumb uh then teach the audience why you
believe that those are wrong there's a
lot of words there Pro believe and wrong
well yeah so I put prove believe and
wrong you know this fell apparently
comes from a monastery that's probably
where he did his schooling you know
whatever he was part of the congregation
I think that's all you actually do all
you do is explain the the normal
accepted theories to your to to the best
of your ability well to to the best of
anyone's you actually do a better job
explaining mainstream physics than
mainstream physic is yeah but see these
fell this fell talks about proof belief
and he says whether it's right or wrong
this is what he's talking about all that
has nothing to do with physics or
science it's got to do with religion
where do you prove well when you bring
the good book you know you convince the
congregation you say oh I have the
evidence the Lord has talked to me or
he's in communication with me when I'm
in the bathroom or whatever right and so
you you show the book and you say I have
proof and why because you're trying to
make them believe you're trying to show
that everybody else is wrong except your
religion or whatever right so yeah we
don't use uh proof belief or wrong but
you can see his language there uh in
science we are only rational okay and
what do we do we do explanations okay
and if you are uh not a scientist uh
otherwise you're not a scientist right
and you are doing religion if you talk
about proof uh belief and uh what um was
the last
one and being wrong or right what is
wrong or right an opinion right I mean
you're always wrong and I'm always right
so I guess uh my religion is better than
yours right yeah really physics deals
with hypotheticals in my mind what
science is all about is if this then
that well it's theories yeah yeah but
but that's what it boils down science
the shortest way the shortest hypo uh
what scientific uh me what what do you
call it scientific method is if this
then that you assume something then you
assume a relationship and then you end
up with a result then you look at that
result and say then comes the religion
part you say ah does that is that really
what how how it works I don't I don't
think so let's try it different if this
and that you just it's almost like um
like with technology where you kind of
try a bunch of things until finally you
find a if that works a then that works
and then a that that you're satisfied
with yeah and and again everybody has a
different satisfaction you know this guy
likes it I mean I can give you a theory
very simple thing that I always use you
know there you find the window broken
and the glass is on the floor so you
have three people who didn't see what
happened they come up with theories of
how that happened one guy said well the
dog jumped through the window another
guy said no Johnny was playing H soccer
or or baseball he the ball went through
the window and another guy might say no
your neighbor he hates you came in there
with a crowbar and broke your window so
these are different theories okay the
assumptions you know one is the dog the
other one's the ball the other one's the
Crowbar those are the assumptions but
then the theory is based on those
assumptions and that's the way it should
work in science or in physics especially
in physics that's why I like the if this
then that because the if this is the
assumptions then is the hypothesis that
is the result but also the result tells
you like how far
there the the belief part comes in
because you could say uh um an angel is
what spins the Earth right and a lot of
people would be satisfied with that but
a lot of people wouldn't but the
satisfied part is the religion part
because you go ah that doesn't sound
right to me it it works as a hypothesis
you know until you dig obviously and I
guess that's where the dissatisfaction
comes in where you go that doesn't
explain a lot there's a lot of there's a
lot here missing so we have to work on
on something well this is the issue the
issue is you know I I always say that
religion especially you know like
Christianity is uh more believable more
acceptable than general relativity for
example because in in uh Christianity
you can say look let us assume that God
exists right so you put a guy there and
you say look this bearded guy that's
that's my God so you can at least
present your object your things you say
this is God okay no problem there we all
understand that we see a guy with a
beard with a magic wand say okay I
understand what I'm seeing i i i
comprehend you can't do that with
general relativity general relativity
says we start with
SpaceTime okay show me space time what
are you going to put a concept there and
say time is bent is that what your
theory is I mean what are you going to
put for SpaceTime so I can imagine God
right I cannot imagine for dimensional
SpaceTime and that's when they say well
you're not supposed to take it so
literally and that's philosophy
you know they lose us no no uh show me
SpaceTime show me how it's warped and
then I'll I'll understand your theory
let alone believe it it's easier to
believe in God believe me okay so uh we
can my turn yeah no well your turn or
anyone who wants to ask questions there
we got more of a more everyone
discussing among themselves not real
questions I saw a few hold on let me see
if I can find it yeah yeah well go ahead
with yours first then uh we'll give you
can answer these next time too but well
if they want to answer at the end you
know uh put a question there at the end
uh start asking questions I saw
questions if they're not good we're not
going to answer them we're not going I
saw some questions about time but let me
just go on to yeah go with your and then
we'll move on but let me start before I
ask the question let me paint paint a
picture if you will oh Jesus I'm in
trouble already well it starts with a
question is there a such thing as time
but before you answer let me answer it
oh you're gonna yeah okay I'll show time
is a concept so by definition it does
not exist easy we won't use the term
time but we do understand that objects
are in motion and with our memory and
intelligence we can tell where objects
have been and where they're going to be
so far so good so far so good just
painting a picture no questions yeah so
if we rewind you're not painting but
you're painting a movie okay move so if
we rewind the matter in the universe
ever further here's the first question
do we end up with the first frame of
this
movie if you keep rewinding where matter
was do we find a spot where it all came
from well how can you do that because
why isn't there a previous frame to that
frame that you're looking for through
the next the last frame isn't there a
frame before that wasn't there a frame
before that one and so so you're saying
there's no first frame yeah you can't
when because the first frame would be
the creation of matter and creation of
matter would be nothing turning into
something with or without God really it
doesn't matter because whichever one you
put in there you have to tell us the
mechanism how did God create you know
something from nothing in his Workshop
well usually people just skip the
mechanism part and they just say well
that's that's the that's the part that I
can't explain yeah no Kidd and you're
saying isn't it much easier to just cut
out the middle man and just matter was
no it's much easier but it's much easier
uh to think that matter can I mean more
rational really uh to think that uh
matter cannot be created from the void
with or without God you cannot turn
something into nothing and nothing into
something and if you cannot turn nothing
into something matter has always been
there floating in nothing that's much
easier to understand that's to say that
something came from nothing and that's
why
creationism in any form Big Bang or
whichever way they want to you know uh
sell it to you uh don't work okay uh
then I guess just to end this part of it
if we use our intellect to fast forward
this movie do we ever end up with an end
frame no because we have another frame
right after that so you're saying
there's no beginning no because the same
thing now you're turning something into
nothing that would be the last frame and
how do you do that I mean how do you
turn an atom into absolutely nothing
even in quantum mechanics they say you
have the virtual particle it comes in
for a split second into the real world
so swiftly that they cannot even measure
it they admit that because it goes back
to where it came from and so so if when
they talk like that they're not dis
making it disappear it's not they're
saying the particle came from nothing in
other words manufactured itself and then
Dem manufactured itself no they're just
saying it came from space and came went
back into space the particle is always
there it never disintegrates and turns
into nothing that's my point so even
under quantum mechanics you don't don't
have uh total disintegration meaning
conversion of Adams into nothing and
nothing into something well just a quick
uh I guess addition to all this is
really the most hopeful part of the Rope
hypothesis that I think is the fact that
if matter was always in motion and
always will be in motion and if we exist
today yeah then it stands the reason
that the drama of evolution and also
part of that being humanity is an Ever
repeating part part of the universe yeah
so so really when you talk about the end
of humanity even really you're only
talking about the end of humanity for
now on Earth and only for now well can't
even say for now because maybe there's
another planet somewhere in the universe
with so many stars and galaxies there's
got to be planets there where uh life
develops similar to the Earth and
there's a human somewhere out there also
developed could happening be happening
now in in several parts of the universe
in fact we may not not be the only
planet right now in the universe with
humans there's got to be maybe you know
who knows how many uh but there's got to
be life in other planets as well as
humans meaning our level of intelligence
which I say is the maximum that the
Universe can can do the the most
intelligent uh that mother nature can
make a living entity is us so so if you
don't think that then you got to
complain to your mama you know no I
would take one step forur I think well
it wouldn't be living anymore by
whatever weird definition you have of
life but AI I think would be the one
step above that but AI is not uh I don't
know it's a weird for I mean it's
depends on how a long story that's a
long story ion get into it also depends
on how you define intelligence Etc ET
but that really is every time I think
about the theories and all the like
pessimism around it when you say we
can't travel to another star really the
most hopeful part of it is that
essentially Humanity is Immortal because
there it just keeps repeating yeah in
the universe in the universe humanity is
Immortal I think life is Immortal in in
general terms okay so let's keep keep
painting this
picture under these uh assumptions
really is what they are yeah what we
could say that the matter in our
universe for just to keep it simple the
matter in our universe is almost like a
bubble that's always just kind of moving
around in space which is nothing right
right it's just ever moving but this
ever moving is also Perpetual there's
no I think we we explained somewhere
that since there's nowhere for this
motion to go not that motion is a
physical object but we kind of
understand that just the fact you know
like the new stop yeah it doesn't stop
but because there's nowhere for it to to
to be transmitted to but still that's
that's that's bad language but kind of
it just like one atom can only uh move
and force other other atoms to move in
the universe so they're all moving with
respect to each other one at can only
move if another one moves it right which
means every time you know there's always
something moving moving one atom to the
other the other at it's a chain reaction
of you know where everything moves
everything that's all it is but then one
uh thing that can be said is for every
action there's a equal and opposite
reaction I guess that would be true
because the motion is always there it
doesn't go anywhere yeah so we have this
of incessant motion so there's no motion
lost but then I guess we do there's no
motion lost because
the there's no way for this bubble to
stand still oh it's not slowing down
slowing down and stopping yeah it's not
speeding up it's not speeding up in fact
in my book I have the situation where we
have what I call the Frozen Universe
right everything is standing still the
only guy that's moving is God right but
the problem with that is and you know
just think of God being in the 10th
Dimension he's like not part of our
universe right if you can imagine that
but everything's standing still and all
God has to do to create motion
throughout the whole universe is move
one atom from here from A to B soon as
he moves it from A to B all the other
atoms change their distance their
location with respect to that
atom yeah but so to move the universe
you need is a mov is
what okay side tangent this is the hard
question that I wanted to ask you as far
as the Rope hypothesis right cuz that's
really what I wanted to ask you about
today cuz you you talk in my opinion you
talk way too much about mainstream
physics and a bunch of theories that
like we get it they don't work but you
definitely don't talk enough about the
Rope hypothesis and the reason I say
that is because even under the Rope
hypothesis there's a bunch of mysteries
that we don't really get into the
nitty-gritty about
because the I guess the weight of
mainstream physics today is just so much
that it's it's like so glaring that you
never get around talking about the a lot
of people have trouble understanding the
kindergart stuff so sometimes you can't
even move beond also also that it's kind
of hard to talk about but today I'd like
to ask you some of those one of them was
one that a friend of mine came up with a
while back when I told them about the
prop hypothesis that being let me paint
this picture you got the sun you I'll
put it in the camera you got the sun you
got and and the ropes are tied from the
Sun to my eye that's why I can see the
sun right right all the atoms in the sun
are connected to every atom in your eye
so the rope twists and it blinds me if
we don't care about the blinding
everyone torqus every every eye torque
every rope torqus every rope torqus yeah
this the the signal I guess starts at
the Sun and then eventually makes its
way to my eye right the torsion the the
move rope doesn't move back and forth
like that but it twists it twists on
this end and over you know at the speed
of light essentially it gets to my eye
yeah they say 8 minutes approximately
but then if you put a wall between that
right okay now it gets complicated we
have the sun wall my eye okay I can no
longer see the sun because of the yeah I
can no longer see the sun because of the
wall but the ropes from the Sun to my
eye are still attached yeah and they're
still torquing into my eye so why can't
I see the
sun you mean why does the light from the
sun the yeah why can't I see the uh sun
because there's at least one atom there
on the other side in the sun connected
to my eye directly there's a lot there's
a lot of there's as many ropes to my eye
as there are atoms in the sun correct
and uh the issue there is that you have
let's go just one atom okay from the Sun
just one atom okay we're going to look
at this Adam in the sun it's connected
to your eye right through the wall right
so it's not connected to the other at it
is connected to all other atoms but
there's one that goes directly to my eye
through a whole bunch of atoms that form
the wall we're just going to look at one
to make right right right so we're going
to look at one atom and that atom is
connected directly to my eye okay so
there's a direct connection between that
atom and the atom in my just one atom
one atom right yeah okay and it's going
through all these atoms right the Rope
is going through all these atoms these
this wall that's there right but I
remember at one point you said that or
or you you at least give this impression
that Adams can't touch the
rope yeah they can't yeah they can't
touch and that's what I would like to
debunk today because I have another
example too okay keep it down for okay
so let's go with this one uh so we have
that Atom from the sun it's connected
directly to my eye yeah okay but what we
have to understand is the following that
same atom that same atom is connected
not only to every atom of the wall it's
connected to every atom of air that
stands between the wall and the Sun and
between the wall and my eye so there's
air wall and the sun yeah there's
there's air and there's a on this side
also the wall to my eye right there's
gazillions of we can remove the air uh
yeah but uh let's leave it in there for
a
second we'll remove it doesn't matter it
doesn't change anything my point here is
there's in fact more atoms of air than
there are atoms of wall if we want to
look at that because you know you have
all these atoms that extend from the
wall all the way to where the air ends
in our planet on the one hand which is
in between the sun and the wall and then
you have all the air from the wall to my
eye right yeah so one atom in the sun is
connected all of them to all the atoms
of air all the atoms in the wall and all
the atoms that are on this side of the
wall as well as the one in my eye but
here we're talking about one atom in the
sun connected directly to one atom in my
eye and one atom in the sun connected to
gazillions of atoms which are all so
connected to my eye okay because I can
see the entire wall in one shot I don't
need to look one atom at a time you know
I look at the whole wall so that means
all these atoms are connected and we're
talking about only one atom right
because that's the one that's connected
to all the atoms right that atom that
yeah and that atom is connected to to my
eye but look at how many rowes I'm
receiving not only from that atom to all
the atoms of air and of the wall all the
atoms of the wall to my eye and all the
atoms of the air around there as well
they're all connected to my eye go slow
and we're trying to figure out one rope
yeah among gazillions of ropes well hold
on there's more atoms than the sun no no
I'm talking right now I'm just talking
about one atom in the Sun so we
understand what the problem is the
problem is that only one atom in the sun
here that we're talking about that one
is connected directly to my eye without
it being connected to other atoms in
between okay that's my point okay so
that one's connected directly to my eye
yeah but that atom is also connected to
gazillions of atoms of the air of the
wall and of the air and of you know that
come to one atom of my eye okay so one
at that same atom of my eye is connected
to a bunch of atoms and that atom of the
sun is connected to a bunch of atoms and
I'm not talking about just a bunch I'm
talking about gazillions of atom and
we're trying to isolate one just one
that's connected directly to my eye yeah
right and so uh you can imagine What's
Happening Here uh maybe
maybe that one you know that signal is
coming directly to me it's not
interrupted at all but it doesn't matter
because I'm not going to be able to see
that one atom because I'm being blinded
you could say by the gazillions of ropes
that are you know coming to my eye what
I'm going to see is the whole picture
I'm not going to see that little one
atom that's just shining right through
all the others I'm only I'm going to see
the whole um wall if I could see the air
I would see the air right that's what I
would see and you're you're trying to
isolate one atom out of gazillion of AD
say oh that one that's connected to my
eye is that interfered or something
happened no what it is it's h it's just
overwhelmed by all the other atoms that
are connected to my eye and I'll give
you a scenario look at this let's say
you make a little peephole in the wall
yeah okay so we make a little the wall
say is I don't know couple inches thick
right yeah I make a little peephole and
I can see there am I seeing and we don't
have to see the sun it could be a tree
right so I see a tree through the people
right am I seeing the tree directly the
answer is no I never see the tree
directly what I see is the the relay of
all the atoms that are in between which
are all the atoms of the air and so the
tree that one atom of the tree just one
atom of the tree is connected to all
those atoms of the air and all those are
relaying the signal through the little
peepole to my eye there's gazillions of
atoms in in the just in the hole that
you made in the wall let alone all the
air that's between the hole in my eye so
you have gazillions of atoms and we're
gonna we're we're gonna isolate one atom
of the tree connected directly to my eye
through all these atoms so so I'm not
seeing the tree directly I'm seeing the
relaying of gazillions of and only one
is connected to me which is not relaying
so let me see if I got this right you're
saying most of what we call Vision or
even Beyond Vision because really
detection if you use a machine yeah
saying even a machine wouldn't be able
to detect sun rays from the Sun through
a wall because really what it does I
mean it it's so minimal what what gets
transferred directly really what when
you get a sunburn it's not really the
sun directly the one the ropes that are
directly from the Sun to your to your
skinra that's a very minimal amount
compared to like I I don't know fraction
I I don't know it would have to be some
wait wait let me finish it would be some
some infinitesimally small compared to
the relaying of right relay by far beats
the straight direct the One That's
directly connected to your eye I think
that's what it is in fact let me give
you a scenario we we have glass right
you see the the sun coming through the
glass and you know getting to the plant
in your flower pot right yeah and you're
saying okay uh the the standard
explanation is all the atoms go through
the glass it allows the Adams to go
through and it's a and it's a hit or
miss according to these people forget
these people we're not talking about
these no no no no no no we're not
talking about these people because I'm
going to make a comparison we don't need
the comparison just once do without the
comparison we need it we need it we need
it so that people see the difference
people think that the photons the little
balls are getting through the glass and
I'm saying it doesn't get through the
nothing gets through the glass okay what
you have is uh the atom in the Sun going
through all the uh atoms of air until
until it gets to the glass there's a
relay of the signals and then when it
gets to the glass that atom all since it
has a a structure that allows for the
vibration to pass to another atom to
another atom to another atom until it
gets through the entire glass and then
from there to your eye so it's all relay
there's only one one that one atom uh is
connected to all these other atoms that
are reling and only one of those ropes
is connected directly to one of the
atoms of my eye no something's wrong
here because if I'm in space no atoms in
between I can still see the sun no relay
there is there are atoms no what do you
mean if I'm went in space in space yeah
no atoms for relaying uhhuh I still see
the
sun yeah yeah you're saying I would
wouldn't see the sun because there's no
atoms to read no no you see you see the
no yeah because uh then then you have
more direct sunlight than relay uh
that's all you have you're saying no no
no first of all let's let's make sure we
understand there's 10 the minus 11 10
Theus 12 T in outer space that doesn't
mean it's completely empty it means
there's a lot of garbage there but it's
not the amount of garbage that we have
here on Earth basically nothing uh
there's a lot of them
uh thousands thousands hold on you're
saying if you remove all the matter
theoretically right we're blind no the
contrary you have no relaying you have
more direct light but we'd be blind well
yeah I mean let's assume you put a
machine there or whatever well to detect
whatever you want to detect well all I'm
saying is a detector okay you put put a
person there but that person would not
see the sun is what you're saying you're
seeing the sun because there's no relay
it's just direct sunlight the direct
light but you're saying most of our
vision comes from the relay almost all
of it almost all light is relay but then
if you remove any relaying you would not
see anything if you remove all relaying
you would see because you see it D there
it would be connected directly to your
eye if if you didn't get blind yeah it's
corrected connected
directly from the Sun to your eye so
since there's nothing else to distract
your eye I guess you would see yes my
point you're not overwhelmed by all the
other garbage air and uh whatever you
have there that you interferes but
otherwise you you have no realin that
means you see it directly that's that's
my experiment for showing that Quantum
is nonsense because you just do the uh
slid experiment in a vacuum very simple
so you do it first uh with normal air
right and then you pump down the system
while while you have the uh fringes
there and what you should see is a lower
intensity because you have less atoms to
relay the
S okay so if you had but if you had a
wall in space yeah you have a wall you
still see more of the wall I guess oh
more to distract right is it a if you
remove that if if you could remove all
the all the air of uh all the solar wind
let's say you remove the entire hold on
hold on hold on you're
saying that's a weird Jos because it's a
proportional issue that's what you're
saying so you're saying since if you
remove everything there yeah you would
see the Sun but only because that's all
there is it's but yeah yeah yeah and and
if you put a a wall most of your vision
is blocked by the wall than the sun
that's and they relay a lot of stuff
there and you you're trying to see one
just to say you're trying to see the
signal coming through one rope compared
the signal coming from a gazillions of
ropes that are coming to that same atom
there's no way you can detect that
single
signal that's a very weird one yeah
something to think about at least and
again uh that's one Theory someone might
come up with a different Theory see if
someone has a
question how do we test the Rope
hypothesis well you don't test it uh
well we do test it we test it every day
with dropping a pen yeah yeah you can't
test because testing means hands and eye
that's what testing mean experiment
right and if you run an experiment you
can't detect that which is invisible and
intangible an object is not that which
is tangible or visible an object is that
which has shape it can be have shape and
not be tangible or visible and so you
cannot detect uh with any experiment you
cannot detect the mediator of gravity
the mediator of light you cannot detect
electricity I mean that's why you have
to theorize you have no other choice but
to visualize and theorize and tell the
world how you think all these things
work that's it you can't test these
things that's why science we don't test
anything because testing means that
you're going to try to get evidence to
convince the the crowd you're just
interested in proof in evidence in
convincing people to believe like you do
and we don't do that in science in
science all we do is explain rationally
the mechanism people can believe then
whatever they want you've talked before
about oneway
touching explain that real
quick uh the I think that the context
was magnetism but I'm not sure because
with magnetism if you I mean I don't
have to explain it but essentially it's
a bunch of threads going like this yeah
and the threads touch the the the stuff
but since they're threads they don't get
touched by the matter I don't know if
that was the context I'm trying to
remember the context not all that but uh
it doesn't come to mind but I I know
what you're talking I'll have to take a
rain check on that one but uh yeah
there's a one way touching you can touch
the ghost but the ghost can't touch you
so to speak that's more or less a
context but I can't remember remember
what the context I think it was
magnetism but I'm not sure the problem I
had with oneway touching just as oh okay
I guess it could be that the fact that
that you know when you try to touch the
mediator of magnetism like you get your
hand close to the magnet there's a field
going on in there you know which is all
the threads going around under the Rope
model you can't touch those ropes you
know they're going right through you
okay but as soon as you put something in
there like a metal or whatever that guy
can touch it so it's like in in that
sense that's one context I don't know if
that's that's not really one way
touching because that only gets moved
because the metal is aligned in such a
way that it gets pulled by these I'm I
remember the I can it doesn't come to I
was hoping you would
remember I'm too
old I'll have to take a rain check on
that one way touching
you well uh does quantum mechanics
explain anything well quantum mechanics
is not in the business of explaining all
of mathematical physics is not in the
business of explaining they're in the
business of describing they describe
mathematically what
uh what they can see what what they can
measure and you can only measure what
you can see and that means that you can
measure maybe
weight uh you can meaning an object you
know how it pushes down the scale you
can measure that you can measure how far
something went in how much time it's
measurements because they're going to do
calculations and make predictions on
where an object can be if it runs so
fast and so on but what they don't know
is what they're looking at and here I I
I've got a scenario here that might be
interesting
to put up here this is this is an object
that's moving okay and you cannot see
what's moving it and so you ask the
question well how come this is moving
you know what's pushing it okay and so
one guy says oh I know I can tell you
here's my theory and he measures how
fast that thing is moving and says
what's happening is all these particles
are pushing the thing okay it's
uh you know these particles coming from
the left
and you know you might have a million
question why don't they come from the
right or from above but right now this
is the explanation the guy says all the
particles are pushing this thing to the
right okay and he does his calculations
he does his measurement he does his um
his equations you know and uh so he says
okay I've proven what that particles
exist no you've only proven how fast
that thing goes You can predict how far
it will go based on uh you know on your
experience because you measure this a
million times and say I can predict now
where it's going to go right and but you
cannot predict you cannot explain you
cannot come up with what is pushing that
thing you are inventing you're saying
well what's pushing it is all these
particles you know and but that's your
theory and maybe your theory is
completely wrong and it's worthless to
do um your math because you're using the
wrong hypothesis let's change the
hypothesis now and let's say there's a
different explanation here's the
explanation okay and what you have is
this thing is torquing and moving along
a screw okay and so this is a different
mechanism for the one that you had which
was the particles pushing the thing okay
this is simply something twirling around
uh some axis right that has all these
screw this uh these threads and so
that's what's move that's what's causing
the movement of this thing and so you
have a different mechanism this
mechanism is not the same one as this
one these two are different mechanisms
so you can have the same equation for
the same for for the same movement of
something in in a certain direction and
that's the problem we have with all
these invisible things that we have out
there we don't know what's causing them
all we can do is speculate and uh give a
um a hypothesis an assumption and based
on that assumption you say okay you know
you know what if right what if uh light
is mediated by rope or you know DNA like
two strand rope Etc right and that's a
what if and you can say well what if
it's particles okay you can make all
those what if and then you find out
which one can work with all your
explanations you know if you can say
well I can explain gravity here I can
explain electricity here magnetism then
you have a pretty good idea that's
probably you know if it walks like a
duck and poops like a duck then probably
it is a duck you know but if you have
the particles and someone say well how
about the particles coming from the
other side well I don't know about that
or you know he can explain pull with the
particles right and and then then that's
when you have to get rid of that
assumption you say well that assumption
is probably not as good as the other one
in other words then you apply uh what is
it um K what is this guy uh uh uh alam's
razor yeah ok's razor ok's razor that's
what you apply you know least least
assumptions one with the least magic I
guess you say I mean the least uh ad
hwks that you can put in there so that's
the only and and again that comes down
to belief also you know you can choose
whichever one you want again in science
we don't believe we just explain
objectively so you understand the
mechanism once that is done what you
know what comes out of the screen is
objective what everybody understands is
something else that's subjective but
what comes out of the screen is the same
for all of us so once you explain the
mechanism that's what comes out of the
screen everybody then can believe or
that's a good seg the next I like this
question how do we know the difference
between an examination and a
narrative
examination I think I think what we're
saying is what we see and what we infer
from what we see because you could see
something happen and you can have a
story for something that happened and it
might not be like how do you tell the
difference between something well well
well this is the issue what comes out of
the screen what comes out of a book or
whatever that's objective now what the
person who reads or the person who
watches The Observer you know he's
subjective and so he might understand
something different from what's coming
out of the screen than the guy next to
him I guess that comes down to the to
the bird the picture of a flying bird
you see a bird right but you can infer
more things from the picture something
like that and we read more into it than
what is there well no but but that that
is kind of our job as physicists also
when you see the pen
fall and you want to explain the
invisible you have to put you have to
infer things that you didn't see yeah in
a weird way you do infer but this is the
point the point is now you make your own
movie yeah because you're going to talk
to the crowd you're going to explain a
mechanism to them so you make your own
movie and you say this is what I
inferred from experience experiments
whatever it doesn't matter what you did
maybe you had a bad dream but the point
is now you put your picture on your
movie right and the movie what's coming
out of the movie is objective you know
the the images coming out of there are
the same for everyone everybody
interprets something different and so
this guy says well I think I have this
Theory the other guy has another theory
or a different understanding but what
comes out of the the movie is the same
for all of us that's objective and
that's what we talk about in science or
physics right physics means that you
make a movie what comes out of the movie
the explanation the mechanism should be
the same for all but for everybody
because that's what's coming out of the
the screen but what people interpret
what the audience interprets and what
each One Believes is something totally
different that's subjective is there a
difference between the words explanation
and
narrative uh yeah because narrative uh
does not narrative is just uh like
usually chronological narrative right
it's just a what happened yeah what
happened but that there's no
interpretation there which is is where
the explanation differs the explanation
is uh puts a fine point on on on
answering a question whereas The
Narrative just just tells you what
happen this is what happened it doesn't
even tell you what happened it's just a
sequence of event it might not even have
happened you can you can even say you
can say that's almost what comes out of
the screen as a narrative but there is
an explanation because you know you have
to you have to show some kind of
mechanism explanation whereas narrative
does not really give you a mechanism
something you can see I got you yeah in
aso's Fable the story is a narrative but
the explanation is the moral of the they
never explicitly say the moral of the
story they never say don't do this
anywhere in the story they just tell you
what it is no they don't they never tell
you the moral of story it's like uh it's
inferred that's the explanation for I
think there is a moral to each one yeah
yeah but it never says it in the in the
Fable it never actually says and that's
why you read a million of them now you
got me I have to do my re mean is if if
someone tells you the the hair and the T
tortoise nowhere in the story do they
say and that's why you should take your
time with things that's never part of
the story that doesn't make sense I
think there is no that's for everyone
cuz you just told I got to look at that
I thought there was okay whether is or
not you could tell the story without
saying it explicitly well that yeah that
true the explanation part basically you
could say the explanation even without
the narrative because you could you
could just say hey this is the moral of
the story not only that yeah people can
for their own moral right that's true I
have a side question okay is there a
gravitational Center to the universe as
in we have all the matter in the
universe and if we got if we calculated
you don't like calculation if we
calculated the average or the center
spot of it yeah would there be any more
like weight there all the ropes pulling
towards it is there is it cancelled is
there no gravity in the center of the
universe because it's all being pulled
apart you're in the very center it okay
but there's uh two universes we can
imagine one is a ball right okay in
which uh there are galaxies on the
inside of the ball and the other one
which is the the same notion as Spa
SpaceTime if we come to think of it and
the other one where all the galaxies are
on the surface no on the
surface neither I thought well no I I
thought thirdd we can imagine okay we
can imagine we we can imagine several
ones okay let me tell you the exact one
I'm thinking okay
um a Galaxy you know the shape of a
galaxy a flat spiral yeah okay at least
the common Galaxy let's imagine the
whole universe as a flat spiral okay
which is one Universe let's take that
one yeah cuz that's the one I kind of
see yeah then you can imagine everything
pointing towards the center I would
think because that's what gravity is if
everything's connected everybody would
tend to go towards the center but does
that mean that if you were in the very
center of I mean it's kind of like the
the question if you're in the center of
Earth if you're in the center of Earth
do you feel any gravity I think the
question is no if the thing is rotating
if the whole thing is rotating then you
have the outward uh push against the
inward pull and you have no gravity you
have maybe a tie you know yeah or
something along I think the same thing
applies to the universe itself if you're
in the center of the universe you also
wouldn't have any pull it'd be like a
gravitational No Man's Land if it is a
center you know the the issue is again
if we had God's point of view if we
could stay outside the universe and look
at the whole matter in the universe we'd
say oh we can see what the shape of it
is and then we could do all our
calculations say okay it's a sphere or
it's just a surface of a sphere or it's
flat you know if we could see that but
unfortunately we don't know what the
universe you know all the matter in the
universe looks like what kind of shape
it has if you had to bet what do you
think the shape of the matter of the
universe looks like I think the the way
you we we have to do it is we have to
hypothesize we make assumptions for each
one of those shapes but you never did
like no I never did that but no uh the
reason is that it would be up to
mathematicians to say uh that is a job
for mathematicians where they would go
in there and say look let's assume it's
a flat disc you know and then what would
be the consequence what would we
observed if it were like that and they
have one hypothesis there and then they
go to another one make another
assumption they say what if it's a
sphere with all the galaxies you know
within it as well and that would give
you a different result and if it's just
on a surface that would give you still
different why would you need mathematics
for that if you no no it's just just to
show you um in this sense if if the
galaxies are not coming towards each
other that means that the whole thing
must be spinning pushing everything out
at the same time that gravity is pulling
them in and then everything more or less
would stay where they're at yeah but
that but that applies to
any shape I guess except yeah in my mind
that always tends to be the same thing
as a Galaxy I can't imagine more or less
it would be like the stars in a galaxy
but remember then you have the the
magnetic field of the universe of all
the galaxies in the universe just
swering around and how does that uh
affect the coming together into the
going apart of galaxies I'm guessing you
a lot of stuff in there magnetism
doesn't have any centrifugal force does
it it's spinning
but it doesn't have any centrifugal
force no no only on the thread that's
spinning but the the point here is that
uh it's not like the thread is flying
away because it's tied already to all
the atoms that are doing the
spinning so so what you have is all
these threads all these magnetic fields
not only of the Galaxy but of the entire
universe the entire universe has to have
a magnetic field how does that play into
gravity you know does it keep things
apart by
you know having uh threads moving in
opposite directions and pushing them
apart against the pull of gravity you
know uh uh you would have to have God's
eyes for all that you know we we only
have a small portion of the universe
where we can see stars and and you're
trying to figure out you know what the
universe looks like or the matter how
it's distributed you know and you can
you can only hypothesize and say what if
that's all you can do how to buy your
book
Bill well you pay money and you
it um how do we know if someone
understands something o there's a good
question again again the the issue the
understanding is the a tough one how do
we know if we if when someone
understands something or if someone
understands no but this is I guess to
answer that let me answer real Qui if
they can tell it back to you right in
your own words that's one issue but what
I say always is you know what comes out
of the screen is objective uh uh you one
talks in the background and tries to
explain what you're observing that helps
a lot but if after all that you still
have a different interpretation well all
you got to do is ask questions and we
clarify each point by point but uh what
we're interested here at least is that
you understand the what we're proposing
we're not trying to convince anyone you
know you can believe whatever you want
you can even trash it and say I'll go
back to Quantum or whatever no problem
you know everybody can believe in
whatever they want my point here is we
try to explain Theory so that you
understand how we think the universe
works it doesn't mean that is the way
the universe works it's just one way
that we're proposing you know it's just
an explanation is what we call science
you know physics explaining how we think
it
works is the Rope Theory a unified
theory I don't know what that means
exactly it is a unified if we're going
to talk I guess you're talking about
Grand unified theory what connects the
micro and the macro yeah that's one
aspect but but the real aspect is what
connects uh gravity to light
electromagnetism and yeah in that sense
it is because we're using the same
mediator that's something uh that
Quantum and general relativity cannot
agree upon because Quantum works with
particles and forces and uh general
relativity works with SpaceTime this
continuous field whatever that is you
know it's a concept and so these two
don't really match and so what they're
doing in Quantum they're talking more
about Quantum Fe field Theory why
because they like the word field and how
does that translate into uh general
relativity well they say the a particle
is the vi local vibration of a field and
so now we have this local vibration of
field which extends all the way to the
other side of the of the universe and
that continuity get allows them to put
waste something on SpaceTime bended and
create gravity that's the that's what um
strength theory is trying to do from a
at least from a quality ative standpoint
right but it it won't work because again
you cannot
reconcile uh a discret particle with a
particle that
extends right like a field extends like
a cobweb extends in this case a
three-dimensional spider web right and
and you cannot reconcile one with the
other and they don't use the spider web
anyways in quantum mechanics all
discrete particles it's only to try to
reconcile it with general relativity
that where they put the field and they
say oh the particle is really a local
vibration of the field but the field
extends only only because they want to
reconcile it with general relativity but
uh that's not how Quantum Works Quantum
works with discrete particles that's how
it's explained that's how it's described
mathematically so there there is no
reconciliation and and that's why they
have to invent strength Theory because
they're trying to they're trying to show
that this little string which is a uh
vibration of a closed loop string yeah
you know is not only locally vibrating
creating the particle but it can link up
with you know chain link kind of thing
and extend throughout the Universe and
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to invent the mathematics for
that but the qualitative part is is
already dead there's no way you can
reconcile it do you think that they do a
better I don't want to say do a better
job but do you think their mathematics
would align better if they had the pidal
uh helix in mind during during light
calculations during gravity calculations
do you think it would help them at all
instead of trying to calculate
everything with particles or waves I
don't if they even factor that into the
mathematics but do you think it would
help if they assuming you had someone
who did all the math on on on light and
and phys and gravity yeah do you think
it would help them in their studies of
mathematics of the universe you think it
would help them to have the Rope
hypothesis in mind well the first thing
we need to understand is that torsion
has been thoroughly mathematized you
know uh the math is already out there so
all you would need to do is say instead
of uh particles traveling in a straight
line or speed now you're talking about
torsion you're talking about a signal or
a propagating along the Rope okay so
that's that's the first thing the math
is already there yeah but if you have a
different uh again like I showed a
minute ago either you push this thingy
you know with particles or it's moving
it's you it's like it's screwing into
something that's a different mechanism
and so if you know that it's a screw
type of mechanism instead of a particle
pushing mechanism now you have a
different uh not mathematics because the
mathematics is really for the visible
stuff oh yeah but you have a different
mechanism that's the thing that you
think if if they if if they took the
Rope hypothesis as a
qualitative uh yeah basis conceptual
basis of how the I guess the the details
of the universe or the basis yeah I
guess I don't know how else to say that
Foundation as a foundation do you think
that would help the mathematics in any
way or change it in any way the
mathematics may not
change I doubt that mathematics will
change them for example I I do schroen
your's equation with my model uh so I
don't need uh I don't need to change the
mathematics shinger equation works
perfectly well in fact works better with
the with the Rope model of the atom than
with a planetary model and even um uh
bores equation where where he created
this notion of the planetary atom works
much better with the with the shell
model which is the one chemistry uses
anyway they use the shell model why do
they call it shell because they've
turned
theal the orbital into a shell into a an
energy level whatever that is
um do you explain sound the phenomen of
sound or the concept that we call sound
do you explain its effects the same way
that uh mainstream physics does yeah
yeah we have no difference with sound
sound is is just vibration of molecules
rare faction and so at that level it's
kind of the same because you're still
using balls as a yeah yeah yeah there
there's we have no difference with h
sound someone says yes I think it is a
unified theory the most awesome one yeah
it is it's it's a unified theory because
we use a single medium to explain
gravity and to explain light and Quantum
and general relativity have not agreed
upon you know the the mediator the that
they're going to use one uses particles
forces and the other guy uses Fields
really because even though Quantum gives
LIF service to the field it doesn't use
the field okay they call them Quantum
field Theory but the field is put in
there just to match it with general
relativity on the other hand general
relativity talks about
extended uh mediators such as field and
SpaceTime which are supposed to cover
the entire universe right and so now
they treat it as a sheet only for the
purposes of giving you a physical
interpretation when and when you say
well what is this sheet well it's four
dimensional you cannot imagine it and
it's a field and that's a concept it
vibrates a concept that vibrates and we
put a ball on top it bends it and you
say is that true we we don't understand
it either but don't ask that question
that's is the sci is the Rope hypothesis
gaining any ground in the scientific
Community well it doesn't uh for the the
few handful of people who manag to come
through our Channel and get acquainted
with it and again we're not here to
convince a creative religion because
imagine you hear one thing your whole
life and it's really the people who are
still have that like nail in their foot
of physics where it's like it still
doesn't it doesn't scratch that itch of
logic like it still didn't particles
don't do it waves don't do it we all
kind of brush over it we use all these
like net that you know SpaceTime gets
bent down and that's why the thing goes
down but why does it go down if we're
using gravity to explain gravity kind of
thing all these things kind of still
stick in the head of of rational
physicists who are doing all this like
they're doing math obviously but they
still want to know what's actually
happening and and that itch was never
scratched by these like half half-ass
qualitative explanations one other thing
I say is that if if mathematicians if
they just stuck to math no problem you
know they're in their world in their own
field but the problem is their math is
worthless if they cannot use that math
to explain causes mechanisms of our real
world and they give you this these
irrational explanations like you know
bending of time is gravity and you say
but that's IR Ral and what they say we
don't understand it either and but we
don't care about that but if you don't
care about if that it's not in your job
description
of why have you crossed the line into
philosophy as they call it right
semantic why are you crossing the line
and trying to give me a physical
interpretation you know that's if it's
not part of your job description and the
answer is very simple if they don't
cross the line their math is totally
worthless yeah they have to give well
it's not worthless but no one's
interested no but it's not that it's
that it's worthless for physics oh yeah
it might be useful maybe to develop
technology you know you can say oh but I
measured here and this is what I got how
much force I got I can use that
somewhere in that sense it's it could be
useful for technology but where it's no
it has no uh purpose or role is in
explanations which is what physics is
about which is what they call philosophy
you know a natural philosophy they used
to call it uh that's what physics is
physics is tell me how this universe
works I want to know how gravity works I
want to know why this pen you know fall
through a BL well it's more I would like
to be able to visualize it accurately
yeah I want to be able to visualize the
details not accurate rationally you can
understand that you can make a mechanism
people look at and say okay I understand
what you're proposing doesn't mean
you're going to believe it just means I
understand what you're proposing but you
cannot understand what these people are
proposing because they're saying say
it's the bending of time what do you
mean the bending of time what how how do
you bend time well we don't understand
it
either why the hell are you giving me
that stupid explanation you know okay
we're an hour 40 in so I'll ask the last
question which is something like well
there's someone who can't find your book
to buy can't find my book it's buy it
yeah you'll see it there in the um what
is it in um my site uh ROP
hypothesis. ROP hypothesis. there's a
section called books you'll see all the
books there oh we got one more question
how is your math my math is great uh
math math like mathematics or yeah yeah
you're math yeah I've got a minor in
math you know but not a major I I don't
like to say it because people say oh
you're a mathematician bill I was very
good in math but it has no you know we
use it engineering as well I was an
engineer for several years but the point
here is that you know math has nothing
to do with physics that's the point that
wasn't the question
how bad are you at math that was no no
I'm very good in I I'm I think I'm
pretty good in math at many calculus
courses and so on you you beat my my
tough question but you did you did good
I'm proud but I I uh I love math I
really like math but math has nothing to
do with physics I tried to get it with
the sun wall question not with the
question I'm trying to answer I'm trying
to answer how the gravity work that's
what I want I don't need any math well
maybe you can help someone with it
offline yeah yeah them directly yeah
okay folks that was fun well we'll see
you maybe next week if we're still alive
right we'll see you then byebye